ich habe heute vor ein kleines spiel mit
euch zu spielen hier ist spiel heißt
erkennst du den youtuber und das
funktioniert so ein kollege von mir hier
hat ein video gemacht wo halt drei
merkmale von youtuber nennt da hat man
ein bisschen zeit und sich zu überlegen
wer das sein könnte so dann sage ich
okay ich glaube der und der ist und dann
sehen wir ob ich recht hatte oder ob ich
vielleicht unrecht hat im thalia hat
bisher zwei videos davon rausgehauen ich
mache heute teil 2 und auch lukas also
kontrabass kanal könnt ihr euch teil 1
anschauen
den link dazu packt ihr euch mal unten
in die beschreibung und ja ich glaube
dann habe ich jetzt eigentlich schon
alles gesagt und wir ziehen uns das
video auch direkt reagiert wenn ich euch
jetzt das video ein und dann würde ich
sagen beginnen wir einfach mal ich bin
sehr gespannt ob ich alle erwarten kann
weil logischerweise als youtuber selbst
hat man doch ein bisschen ahnung so wäre
die kollegen sind und wer nicht aber wir
beginnen
erstens aufwändig geschnittene videos
asiate und wohnt in einer wg okay das
ist glaube ich julien da bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher ist ja okay das ist
schon mal richtig aber gut eine wg und
aufwendige videos es der inbegriff von
aufwendigen videos redet mit seiner tür
albaner und wohnt mit seinem die fw
zusammen ok redet mit einer tür ich
meine es gibt nur einen der so dumm ist
k s freak aber ist der albaner also k s
free geredet ja ständig mit seiner tür
in seinen videos aber ich bin mir
wirklich nicht sicher ob er auch albaner
ist glaub dir eine gute er wohnt ja auch
mit karten zusammen aber ich tippe jetzt
mal auf kers trick ist es okay habe ich
auch geraten leuten geredet in dem video
glaube ich jetzt ausnahmsweise nicht mit
seiner tür wurde durch einen
kooperations video bekannt lesbisch und
liebt island also liegt island und
lesbisch wird wahrscheinlich melina
sophie seien aber wurde durch ein
kooperations video bekannt also ich weiß
nicht wo durch sie bekannt wurde okay
also gut zu wissen man lernt hier
anscheinend auch noch was bei den videos
aber gucken wir mal ob ich recht hatte
überhaupt ist
hier ist melina mehr als fünf personen
alles ausländer und alle schwarze hat
schwarzkopf ok alle schwarze haare hätte
ich nicht unbedingt bewusst aber dass da
rechts steht schwarzkopf professional
es gibt ja skk schwarzkopf kanal
ich weiß nicht ob das 5 sind aber wir
schauen einfach mal ob ich recht hatte
und jetzt skk baurecht
ihr merkt schon ihr könnt auch gerne mal
in die kommentare schreiben wusstet ihr
immer wer es ist also hättet ihr auch
gewusst dass das hier schwarzkopf kanal
ist weil ich würde schon sagen dass ich
schon relativ ahnung habe einer der
ersten youtuber etwas pummelig und türke
ich darf als erster einen roman im
moment moment to go to guy von tuba
beatbox und ja es ist ja ja today leute
was los ja bisher fünf von fünf erwarten
doch unbedingt bei luca fallen guckt wie
gut er darin ist weil ich glaube 555 ist
schon ziemlich gut aber du kannst
natürlich auch selbst schon ewig auf
youtube und kennt wahrscheinlich auch
sehr viele bekannt also kuchen tv-macher
anmerkt matan nicht mehr fahren ein
smart tv jetzt mehr und dann leute bin
ich ziemlich gut mir ein abo dallas dank
riesen justin bieber fan interessiert
sich sehr für fashion viel youtuber
können ihn nicht ab okay das ist
garantiert hierarchie oder miguel pablo
weil die sind beide so wandeln der
justin biebers also das ist ja schon
schwieriger weil das nicht so eindeutig
ist ich tippe auf revanche
heute wird es ist miguel paulo verdammt
gut stimmt er hat er sogar sein
merchandise von justin bieber inspiriert
so nummer acht okay das war der erste
bin ich falsch macht der flops ist mit
einem youtuber aus dem ufo zusammen hat
kleine stadt tucson haben das kann ja
nur die sein weil wert songs aus dem
ufer noch eine freundin nur dehner und
party macht keine videos ja es ist schon
wusste ich doch ich glaube es ist
wirklich sehr sehr sehr interessant wie
viele von euch auch so viel richtig
hätten weil enden da bin ich sofort der
youtube profil sucht die was auch immer
und kennen deshalb so viel oder aber die
fragen sind halt relativ leicht aber ich
glaube das macht so oder so einfach echt
schlecht fanden das zu spielen
so gut wie alle weiblichen youtuber
finden inhalt türke und hat live acts
nach youtube deutschland emrah
garantiert er im reifen korrekt er die
information dass alle weiblichen youtube
finden interessant ja ist immer klar
macht sehr viel mit lena sein namen
besteht aus zwei buchstaben die doppelt
vorkommen von itt sie kommen schon hier
hocken schiri wenn du das siehst du hier
mache eine extrem version und dann
probiere ich zu machen
also das ist so was von ihr sie da
verwette ich alles drauf ist gleich der
sie schaute sie noch mal sorry dafür
dass ich beim letzten telefon
verarschung video ein bisschen verarscht
habe aber ja der gute idee nummer elf
okay es geht noch weiter wurde durch
einen youtube bekannt er mittlerweile
auf typische aufgabe der türke betreibt
nebenbei auch einen kanal mit seiner
freundin das nein jetzt muss ich passen
merck matan ok medien verfolge ich nicht
hat eine day4 weil deshalb es deshalb
fast nie was hoch nein jetzt habe ich
gesagt es ist stehe weil ich weiß hat ja
auch so eine sache aber es ist stehe
garantiert mit fast nie was hoch da war
es klar ja es ist steht jemand okay
natürlich so ein mist leute egal ich
weiß nicht ob wir das zähler nicht müsst
ihr entscheiden etwas pummelig macht
news videos über youtube deutschland hat
früher stark gelistet ist respekt
natürlich müsste würde ich darauf wetten
dass der flash back an der stelle auch
noch mal dicke props an tahir für dieses
video weil es ist echt mega aufwendig
allein das zu ändern hat wahrscheinlich
ewig gedauert deshalb wenn ihr bock auf
noch mehr so videos und auch besser auf
seinem kanal verlinkt ich mich auch in
der beschreibung und dann würde ich
sagen machen wir erstmal weiter trio
einer der ersten youtuber haben
aufgehört mit youtube weitet ihr
bestimmt leitete
und was ist es das ist ja okay auch das
habe ich schon wieder geraten
ich bin einfach zu gut leute mit youtube
angefangen und jetzt musiker sein bester
freund welcher auch in der band ist hat
auch youtube gemacht masse tattoos und
farbige habe ja gut also sicherlich ist
die rede von
aber es ist okay ich sagte ja ich habe
erstmal so adi ist ja so was heißt der
unbekannte aber so der erst weniger
gesicht finde ich von von den beiden
wurde früher oft als schwul abgestimmt
in seinen videos war eine zeit moderator
bei viva hat eigene eine eigene
modekollektion okay da können hier
vorstellen dass manche von euch jetzt
schon probleme hätten aber es ist sami
slimani wenn ihr mich fragt und das ist
samy slimani wusste auch erraten leute
das so leicht für mich
nummer 17 schon mittlerweile drei brüder
ein break kanal und fitness freaks ich
glaube die leute es tut mir echt leid
dass ich immer alles weiß und brad
brooks war es das jetzt so das waren
alle okay leute so leute ich habe jetzt
tatsächlich die allermeisten erraten ich
weiß nicht wie es zusammen geschnitten
habe das nicht irgendwie langweilig oder
sonst was ist auf jeden fall vielen dank
noch mal an tage dass sie das video
verwenden durfte und jetzt falls ihr
noch bock habt auch mehr davon checkt
unbedingt lukas video aus das ist ganz
oben verlinkt in der beschreibung
ansonsten was ihr noch wissen müsst es
gibt da so ein kleines datum und an
diesem tag beginnt minecraft maus das
ist in minecraft projekt von mir und
luca kann müsst ihr unbedingt
reinschauen wenn es soweit ist und ja
ansonsten was gibt es noch zu sagen
keine ahnung hat einen schönen tag wenn
es euch gefallen hast lasten like da und
bis zum nächsten mal tschüss falls ihr
das noch nicht getan habt könnt ihr mich
übrigens hier gern abonnieren und hier
mein letztes video anschauen das wollte
ich noch gesagt haben und ja dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal tschüss